et d'ailleurs on va en parler avec
charles milliards qui est pdg à la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec bonjour monsieur médias sociaux
alors nous vous en faites vous aviez
écrit lettre au premier ministre le go
pour demander le déconfinement des
édifices à bureaux est ce que vous êtes
satisfait aujourd'hui où est ce que vous
êtes à 25% satisfait excellente question
je voudrais enfin une bonne nouvelle
pour les centres villes au québec mon
esprit particulièrement du centre-ville
de montréal avec les autres associations
patronales différentes associations
ciation économique
on a effectivement être simplement je
pense que la mesure aujourd'hui elle
doit être salué
nous on est très heureux je pense une
vigueur et une autre étape vers un
retour à la normale et un jour chaque
jour le pain et les flexibles et les
agiles comme vous l'avez dit notre jeu
c'est eux c'est une limite c'est pas un
objectif
est ce que vous auriez préféré
pourcentage plus élevé je ne sais pas
moins que ce que vous demandez aux
gouvernements 30 40 pour ça prenant avec
une directive pour justement que le
gouvernement de départ la porte si vous
voulez des tours à bureaux
particulièrement centre-ville de
montréal et c'est ce qui était avec
l'annoncé aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est aux envoyeurs est
décidé par mesure de leur leur niveau de
préparation à recevoir leur envoyer a
décidé donc s'il veut se rendre jusqu'à
25% le ministre boulet a mentionné que
la mesure était évolutive
donc évidemment on souhaite que ça aille
plus vite que l'insecte pour ça
le pays après le climat possible mais en
même temps on va voir comment ça se
passe mais vous comprenez aussi
effectivement qu'un contexte sanitaire
qui dit si l'on veut éviter tous les
contacts
alors on n'a pas le choix de suivre les
recommandations de la santé même si
parfois ça va pas suffisamment
rapidement comme on le voudrait
finalement non complètement les
québécois se promènent déjà deux
semaines on pense que si les milieux de
travail sont sont respectueux de la
peine de mentionner ce soir à quel point
le travail de sienne nécessité souvent
dans l'ombre est exceptionnel dans le
camp des crises actuelles
alors si les employeurs respecte ça
c'est pas plus dangereux tarit pas
sécurité que dans un autre endroit
partout qu'elle est et on pourrait dès
confinant conclu rapidement assurément
est-ce que ça va permettre de
revitaliser un peu des centres villes
qui ont souffert énormément lors des
derniers mois gama est probablement que
plusieurs de vos auditeurs n'ont pas eu
l'opportunité sera le centre ville de
montréal
des dernières semaines c'est vraiment
difficile alors c'est à de montrer à
tout l'écosystème économique du
centre-ville que le retour aux affaires
et des deux je vous dis non quatre ans
qu'il est je parle ne vaut rien mais
aussi le centre et le québec et les
édifices à bureaux partout en région
nous chez nous on a un intérêt
particulier le bruit l'ensemble des
régions
mais globalement il est grand temps on
réalise que le télétravail c'est très
bien fait il m'a décideurs ont pu
mesurer la balance télétravail dans les
dernières semaines
mais si vraiment complémentaires à quel
point les commerces les restaurants dans
les centres-villes pas seulement à
montréal
à quel point ils ont souffert lors des
dernières semaines derniers mois et
coûter encore une fausse centre-ville de
montréal c'est presque apocalyptique des
nettoyeurs en tous cas auto finalement
vu travail de bureau a été passablement
amoché il ya des restaurateurs endroits
qui ont décidé de ne pas ouvrir
d'attendre d'avoir une manne de jean
suffisant pour soutenir leur modèle
d'affaires
il faut respecter ça aussi mais
globalement je pense que si on april 25
% des gens qui retournent au bureau ça
se passe très bien et qu'on peut penser
à 50 75 % peut-être au début de l'année
prochaine ce sera déjà très très bien et
je pense que c'est à de démontrer
justement votre la reconnaissance et
d'affection on one au centre-ville en
revenant en toute sécurité
oui est-ce que vous avez d'ailleurs
abordé la question du télétravail est ce
que ça pourrait en quelque sorte
amoindri tué en partie nous centre-ville
lors des prochaines années c'est quelque
chose qu'on va voir évoluer on l'a déjà
vu plusieurs grandes entreprises
proposition du travail est parti
maintenant dans leur modus operandi
alors on verra je pense que plusieurs
gens voudront
bénéficiez des avantages télétravail
ceci candy passe quelque part les
employés ont quand même arrêt avoir des
contacts avec leurs collègues de travail
et avec leurs clients aidera sans cela
on peut soutenir l'écosystème des
centre-villes je pense de cette façon là
donc les 228 ça va être intéressant a vu
de l'évolution du travail au canada et
au québec est de voir comment ça peut
donner aussi des conditions dans la
bouche intéressante ou pas donc les
employeurs vont vont peut-être en
compétition aussi la tuera ça va être
intéressant suivent mais télétravail et
si je peux me permettre c'est aussi une
façon de transformer son entreprise avec
plusieurs façons de faire et nous on
veut juste un mac les entreprises
partout au québec profite la crise en
guinée pour se réinventer changer leur
innover et à être au diapason de ce que
leurs employés va l'avoir
oui vous parlez de se réinventer
d'innover ce qu'il va falloir repenser
également nos centres-villes à moyen
long terme
est ce qu'il pouvait y avoir délit josé
les rives ont parlé soit du télétravail
mais on parle aussi des fois du duc au
travail alors des gens qui
travailleraient dans le même espace est
ce qu'on va devoir revoir complètement
le système du travail
ça va être quelque chose cette façon de
travailler est très intéressant au
niveau du centre ville
je sais qu'il ya eu plusieurs
organisations à montréal oui on l'espère
et pour retrouve également au sud et
centre ville on sait à quel point c'est
un portable vous l'avez dit également il
ya toutes sortes de commerces des
restaurants qui gravitent autour de cela
merci beaucoup reçu milliards d'avoir
été avec nous et on espère que ça reste
une course à pour augmenter à 50 60 70
dans un avenir rapproché
merci non respect des règles
effectivement merci